E aí
[Aplausos]
o Guimarães Rosa poetizou viver é um
rasgar-se e remendar-se no final de 2019
eu tava na praia no finalzinho de tarde
e ela pra beira do mar ficava olhando
assim aquela imensidão do azul do céu e
do mar eu senti um vazio muito grande
dentro de mim talvez fosse algum sintoma
da menopausa Talvez as incertezas da
vida transbordar assim dentro de mim
talvez alguns ciclo que se despedisse
Janeiro tiveram infinitos dias eu fiz
alguns planejamento do ano e depois
aquelas causa de carnaval eu voltei né
De Volta para o meu trabalho e eu saquei
que aquele ano seria desafiador 2020
chegava com tudo só que não podia
imaginar o quanto ele seria eu tive uma
infância bem bacana uma cidade pequena
uma vida muito simples filha de um
engenheiro agrônomo de uma dona de casa
Neto de um Alfaiate e de duas avós com
mãos muito habilidosas
se eu fugir desesperadamente das
ciências exatas E virei uma
Universitário de direito e nessa
metamorfose toda da vida das
manualidades elas eram muito fortes na
minha vida trazia muito isso lá da casa
dos meus avós né A questão de fazer a
mão de fazer manual
e há dez anos atrás eu consegui o meu
pai para tomar um café aí eu falei papo
reto direto eu falei para ele pagar olha
só eu queria te comunicar que eu vou
deixar de ser advogada e você é um
Marquesa eu vou empreender
e a notícia né bombástica ele se
acomodou na cadeira aí logo deu a
resposta filha se quiser ser uma
profissional de retaguarda segue onde tu
tá saindo direito mas se tu quiser ser
uma profissional de Vanguarda vai lá
empreende eu sei que a tua decisão está
tomada tu sabe que a segunda opção é
mais difícil
é mas é servido entre os olhos de café
aí ele mar Egeu os olhos aí o assunto
mudou o pai nome do campo uma pessoa
muito simples ele sabia que na vida a
gente precisava arar plantar esperar
acolher cuidar na e ele sabia que a
filha do meio dele você vai avaria de
uma forma muito corajosa essa estrada do
desconhecido em busca da autenticidade
em busca de algo a mais né Eu sempre
gostei de escrever através das palavras
eu consegui traduzir com meu sentimento
naquele momento as palavras engraçados o
direito dela espaço a textos mais
despojados né e eu também sempre gostei
muito da estrada gostei muito do ele vir
seja trabalho seja a lazer seja para
diminuir algumas saudade a estrada sem
foi muito importante na minha vida
depois dessa conversa com dinheiro muito
curto mais uma vontade imensa
e eu aluguei um sobradinho muito pequeno
em Porto Alegre tentei arrumei decorei e
aquele espaço passou a ser o meu mundo e
passou a colher pessoas do Brasil
inteiro quem Olá
e em busca de descobrir as suas próprias
histórias isso é uma coisa muito
incrível assim que eu conseguia
despertar nas pessoas aquela mensagem de
que a vida é uma só a gente pode mudar a
qualquer momento só que tinha um
problema eu não sabia dizer que que eu
fazia eu não sabia dizer uma palavra O
que faz o que que tu é não sabia dizer
isso é uma coisa que me incomodava muito
o meu trabalho de sempre foi muito
intuitiva sempre gostei muito de
trabalhar com as mãos em comunicação com
o meu coração mas eu nunca seguir
aquelas regras perfeitas da costura
perfeita do tricô do crochê então eu
nunca fui uma costureira uma tricoteira
uma crocheteira eu sempre foi uma pessoa
muito manual que eu me me colocava no
mercado como uma artesã né e dessa
maneira eu fui trabalhando para
valorizar esse trabalho de artesão o
trabalho de artesão Ofício de artesão
ele ainda segue um preconceito muito
grande né
É mas sei que tem alguma coisa que me
cochichava no ouvido e que diz assim
Aldo Sena além do Artesanato tem alguma
coisa aí dentro e eu buscava o que que
seria esse algo a mais nela artesanato
ele podia ser uma ponte Mas tem alguma
coisa que eu buscava atrás de mim
a cair muitas vezes Ralei o joelho
levantei não a vida como ela é e nesse
momento é o momento de mudar de fase
mudar de fase no momento entendi que eu
tinha um amor transbordando dentro de
mim e que através desse amor eu
conseguia descrever através do
artesanato ou seja com as mãos e com o
coração é podia transbordar esse amor eu
entendi que aquele amor e não precisava
ficar preso dentro de uma casa ele podia
seguir comigo numa mala com rodinhas e
com as minhas mãos e com meu coração eu
voltei para estrada eu escrevi um livro
sobre essa jornada o meu Relicário de
afeto seria muito mais que o livro ele é
um convite uma reflexão para que a
pessoa para que o leitor busque a sua
essência a sua história EA conexão do
seu passado com o seu presente porque às
vezes a gente se conecta a gente se
perna de tudo aquilo que faz parte da
nossa vida e a boneca de pano a partir
daquele momento viraram a Cerejinha do
meu bolo
e a Cerejinha do meu bolo bom foi
através das bonecas de pano que eu já
consegui comunicar com mais de 4.000
alunos de maneira presencial de maneira
online para que eles também possam
contar histórias com as suas mãos e com
o seu coração Ou seja que eles possam
contar as suas histórias foi através das
bonecas do universo lúdico das bonecas
que eu consegui entender o meu jeito
adulto de expressar aquilo que eu queria
eu não digo que eu sou uma pessoa que
faça bonecas eu conto história através
dos bonecos se a gente pensar que cada
aluna é uma forma nos mais uma vez que
eu penso assim se eu pensar que cada
aluno que eu já tive perto que eu já
comuniquei ligamos né são quatro mil
pessoas se cada um distribuído duas ou
três sementinhas a gente vai ter 12 mil
sementes já tem 12 pessoas entendendo
que podem acessar o seu coração e
trabalhar com as mãos é isso para mim é
uma coisa muito importante eu acho que a
vida não é o que a gente acumula a vida
que a gente espalha
é tão isso para mim é especial mas
voltando na
e lá no início de 2020 em março meu pai
partiu sem aviso prévio foi na salinha
tendo e que antecede o a Deus eu disse a
ele tudo o que eu sentia eu disse ele
tudo que a gente aí a gente conseguiu se
conectar no amor e no medo o pai uma
pessoa muito Germânica muito dura EA há
poucos anos eu consegui assim estender
uma ponte entre aquela pessoa Germânica
e esse meu coraçãozinho né pessoa aqui
fala com o coração e com as mãos e essa
pontizinha eles têm dia recolher toda
vez que eu precisava mas nesses nove
dias de UTI que a gente passou juntos Eu
estendi essa ponte falei agora é o nosso
momento eu vou curtir isso da maneira
que a gente pode e que a gente merece
afogada e lágrimas eu consegui cantar
como é grande o meu amor por você quando
o pai se despediu da vida
e eu consegui eu cantei eu consegui
fazer essa conexão e foi para mim muito
muito especial
e o pai vivia no campo e no campo o
trabalho não para três dias depois dele
partir cheguei eu lá de mala cuia e
Coração Despedaçado
e foi na exata semana que a pandemia
chegou no Brasil não Aqui as pessoas
todas pararam se recolheram e o que eu
sentia dentro de mim era um grande
desespero eu só sentia desespero né a
filha artista e cosmopolita vai para o
meio do mato no meio da roça em zona
rural para honrar o trabalho de uma vida
inteira com as suas irmãs com a sua mãe
com a sua família Mas eu havia o meu
trabalho para honrar também como é que
eu ia fazer essa comunicação o meu
trabalho é uma estrada também é
importante para mim e Honrar o trabalho
do meu pai também era então isso me
assustou demais eu não consegui entender
né esses movimentos
e eu tinha uma comunicação diária com
100 mil pessoas mais pessoas do que
moram na cidade na minha cidade natal
que é uma cachoeira do sul que tem 80
mil habitantes e eu precisava conseguir
me comunicar com elas com essa dor que
eu tava sentindo eu não queria
transmitir aquela felicidade virtual eu
estou feliz as coisas estão bem eu não
estava feliz as coisas não estavam bem e
aí nesse ano entre Intempérie do tempo
burocracias lavora gado dificuldades
e eu consegui entender os movimentos da
natureza as estações eu consegui
entender que aquela nova vida me
despertou simples e o sempre sempre fez
muita parte do meu dia a dia né havia na
fazendo uma casinha uma casinha Sobre
Rodas que lá no sul chamo de boa tanta
Eu puxei essa casinha para perto da casa
dos meus pais e ela virou meu refúgio
ela virou meu refúgio ela começou a
entregar assim momentos muito bons ela
tava meio mal tratada né varre um
pouquinho e aí o pintei a casinha por
dentro ela ficou mais claro ficou mais
bonitinha coloquei um colchão coloquei
uma mesa tinha meu computador uma
máquina de costura era o momento assim
de na zona as vagas eu consegui me
reconectar comigo mesmo e consegui me
reconectar com as pessoas que estavam lá
do teu lado esperando alguma mensagem e
eu podia dizer olha não tá tudo bem mas
eu tô aqui e o tempo vai melhorar E aí
logo eu fiz 49 anos toda toda
não existe assim aquela máxima de que no
aniversário da gente a gente renasce né
um novo ano e ali renasceu uma nova
Luciana e de dentro daquela casinha de
três metros quadrados eu consegui me
conectar com o meu mundo era uma casinha
que morava lá na fazenda quando nós
vamos crianças ela não tinha nem
banheiro é um quartinho e eu consegui me
conectar através da janela daquela
casinha eu consegui ver o mundo eu
consegui ver que a vida e que a natureza
elas estavam ali Elas Não paravam elas
não seguiam isso foi me fazendo muito
bem e eu consegui cicatrizando né essas
minhas dores essas minhas reflexões as
minhas redes cobertas
e o tempo é sábio E ele nos estende a
mão e depois de pintar a casinha por
dentro Eu puxei uma tomada fiz um fio de
uma cara meio e coloquei uma luz
parecida com essa aqui e a casinha ficou
iluminada e depois eu pintei por fora um
azul discreto na casinha do lado de fora
com um vermelho intenso nas portas na
porta na porta a única pote na janela
seu precisava me reconectar com as cores
acho que eu tava meio desbotada né
naquele período e nesse momento eu volto
a costurar as bonecas de pano e eu volto
a sorrir com todos os dentes isso para
mim foi uma coisa muito legal porque meu
sorriso estava muito tímido e não
mostrava mais ausência isso para mim foi
um abraço de esperança e nesse ano que a
vida se mostrou tão dura como toda a
Face tem seu verso eu consegui de alguma
maneira no meio daquele causa emocional
a buscar reflexões buscar soluções e
buscar um novo olhar para a vida com a
mistura da vida da cidade com a vida do
campo da Luciana em criança da Luciana
adulta e que eu podia fazer essa mistura
toda na E por que a vida ela tava aí ela
tava ali em constante movimento isso
para mim foi muito importante eu tomei
decisões duras em relação àquelas
incertezas da vida que me acomodavam me
incomodava lá no início do ano lá no
final de 2019 no eixo 2020 eu entendi
que cuidar é dos valores mais
importantes o cuidado o zelo o olhar
cuidado outra e cuidar de nós mesmos e
isso para mim foi uma coisa muito legal
e a partir daí eu consegui construir a
minha colcha de retalhos com todas essas
dores Com todas essas descobertas e Com
todas essas alegrias e com sorriso no
rosto de novo né uma colcha de retalhos
tamanho king-size
o e nessa metáfora de vivências né ponto
a ponto cada experiência sem regra de
costura perfeita eu entendi o verdadeiro
vínculo entre o passado e o meu presente
Oi e a Lilo eu renasci renasci nas
utiliza encantadora das coisas simples
aí permanência da vida me fez
re-significar uma série de detalhes que
me eram importantes e
e eu comecei a entender o poder da
contemplação do Olhar
e do mundo dos tempos
e para colheita para o plantio porque a
gente espera porque a gente busca
e com o seu tempo não hoje eu não sinto
mais necessidade de dizer o que que eu
sou em uma só palavra porque eu sinto
aqui dentro que eu consigo de alguma
maneira tocar o coração das pessoas e eu
recebo esse esse retorno com muito amor
e com muita gratidão isso para mim é
muito especial
e esse a vida me desafiou a ter coragem
Eu acho que eu consegui sim mergulhar De
cabeça nessa jornada e a casinha casinha
Sou eu por dentro e por fora e também na
versão poética de Guimarães Rosa com A
Verdade de Cada rasgo com a coragem de
ter ser com amor a nossa própria
história porque viver é um rasgar-se e
remendar-se
E aí